continuing our look at the race for
Clark County Commission three seats are
up and right now we're speaking with the
commission chair currently for district
G Jim Gibson commissioner Gibson good to
see you again good to see you so uh
let's first talk about something that
I've asked all the other current members
of the commission about an issue that's
been happening in Clark County for a
long time now with Rob tell us the
public administrator who's now accused
of murdering the Las Vegas
Review-Journal investigative reporter
Jeff gearman
walk me through a little bit of what you
as a commissioner and as commission
chair knew with regards to the public
administrator's office before everything
took place
the only things we knew were about was
about relationships workplace
relationships that were strained and we
made the decision to bring in Mike
Murphy who had been a coroner an
incredible leader and a he's a talented
Problem Solver to
um
watch over things the employees there
are Clark County Employees the elected
official is elected by all of us
and it was determined that the smart
thing to do was to get kind of a referee
somebody who knew the processes of the
county in there to help work through
whatever the issues were and there were
there were I think like happens when
there's conflict people took sides and
uh it made a lot of sense to do that
Mike did a wonderful job of helping us
make our way through a difficult time
what of course no one could have
predicted was that the final outcome
would be what it was what else could
have been done or do you believe that
the county and as you as a commissioner
should have done more
well I think we did everything we knew
to do I don't yet know what was
underneath all of this which would lead
to the aggression that no but just on a
are you talking about the personnel
there I'm not I guess I'm more focused
on that than necessarily Mr Telus
um was there anything else that you
could have done for those people uh in
that office well I think we did what we
could do for the people there
we took some administrative
responsibility just because there are
people we don't run the office we're not
the legal officer that can do the things
that need to be done although Mike is
deputized so he can function there you
know if there were anything maybe the
public administrator shouldn't even be
in elected office could we have done
something well I know one of our members
tried to do that when she was in the
legislature but and I think it takes the
legislative action to do that obviously
final question here we understand that
the obviously the prosecution is going
that's a whole separate deal but just at
the county offices right now what has
been going on with regards to the public
administrator's office to sort of the
machinations leading up to this what has
it been like at the County office since
this took place well we've
some of the people who were there are
not there any longer they've been
reassigned to other departments Mike
Murphy has taken responsibility for
basically everything in the office
there's an election going on right now
and eventually someone will be elected
to fill that post so we're going to
continue down the path of managing it
through Mike Murphy through the election
we'll make a determination as to
appointing after the election it has
nothing to do with who wins it has more
to do with what makes the most sense
uh let's switch gears let's talk about
the the election itself you're up for
re-election obviously
um and let's talk about what's happened
in the last couple of years with the
County Commission
um the biggest challenges you've had to
deal with through covid and everything
else how would you grade your
performance getting through the depths
of the pandemic
frankly I think we worked well together
there was always going to be conflict
both internally because we have
different views about things and
um with others you know the business
Community was frantic to get back open
early on no one was coming to Las Vegas
so because we're dependent upon tourism
and travelers and Airlines were shut
down and there were empty buildings it
it was something that was it didn't
require a lot of action on the part of
anyone but it was not we who were
shutting down or making determinations
about
what was essential that was a
gubernatorial determination what we did
was we worked within the confines of his
emergency powers to enable a restart at
some point and we were working very hard
trying to make the case where it was
appropriate that it was time to reopen
some things and to allow other things to
begin to get ready to be open that was
something that we did on the Fly because
there was no handbook for that we had
never operated under a circumstance ever
where we had a gubernatorial emergency
order that took all power
to the governor's office
we people who would say that we should
have done this or we should have done
that maybe there are some things we
learned that we'd do a little
differently but I think all in all we
did a really good job and you know I was
on the phone and with both state leaders
and with businesses we had issues
related to liability that were
especially important and top of mind
with many of these folks we had
landlords who had locked out tenants and
tenants had product and goods that they
couldn't even secure they were very
concerned about rent what happens to
their rent there's no provision in their
agreement that says reliably that they
don't have to pay rent right time but on
that note you're talking about you know
there's no real playbook for this and we
did what we could given what took place
from from Carson City
there are a lot of people including your
opponent who would who are blaming
anyone who was in office during the
depths of the pandemic for what has now
taken place in the struggles for
business to get back on track what do
you tell those people you tell the
voters who say you've got us into this
mess or you maybe didn't help us get
through the mess the best way well what
I would say is that the mess was one
that wasn't created by any politician
fair enough right so at the end of it
all we had a Health crisis that needed
to be addressed and to help we
determined that our health district was
the principal source of the expertise
and the information and guidance when it
came to the health issues and we worked
very hard to pay attention to what the
Southern Nevada Health District was
advising us we have members from elected
members from the cities in the county
that serve on the board there so we had
whatever minimal input a politician can
can give at the same time we had orders
that were both presidential and
gubernatorial that were affecting
everything travel was not controlled by
us so businesses who wanted to be open
and who even when the time came who
could have reopened had lost the
opportunity because there were no
customers for them it was one of those
times where I'm sure that there were
things that we would do differently
although we're in the process
continuously of trying to figure out
what we might have done differently one
of the big issues really was that we
weren't in control of enough some have
said we should have sued somebody well
I'm a lawyer I've been in court I know
how long it takes to get through we
would still be litigating some of those
issues that wasn't the right thing to do
the right thing to do was press hard
make ourselves a room at the table so
that we are providing the representation
of our businesses and our Industries and
our people in southern Nevada the school
district was was doing it whatever it
felt it needed to do we had no control
over it I don't know who all is saying
it but some have said well we masked
children we didn't mask children we had
no control over what was happening in
the schools but what we did learn was
that the broadband service is inadequate
in this Valley and we have an ongoing
process right now where we're going to
address that we're we're getting very
close
to real solutions we'll talk a little
bit about moving forward in just a
second here sort of post pandemic and if
you're re-elected your next 40 years I
also want to just touch on something
else that your opponent has brought up
and you know you've had a long political
career you were the mayor in Henderson
you've you've been in politics for a
long time here there have been uh
accusations made with regards to ethics
campaign financing debt from when you
are the mayor of Henderson instead of
lingering Financial fiscal issues that
are that are sort of being brought up to
be critical of your performance how do
you tell voters that you're the best
Steward of their money that when you're
in office you're the best person to
represent them and get the county moving
forward well first of all in the city of
Henderson we operated on a really tight
budget and always always were operating
within the parameters that were assigned
so there was no debt you know when there
was a loose comment that wasn't intended
to convey the message that was conveyed
when the mayor who succeeded me said I
inherited a 90 million dollar deficit
well there are no deficit what he
inherited was a circumstance a recession
that was rolling in as I was leaving
office and so we had already done a
voluntary retirement program and we'd
saved considerable money on payroll we
were cutting back in areas that were
really important keeping we had even
debate about do we leave rec centers
open or do we close them no we need
those more than anything they're paid
for people don't have to pay to go there
we we were having those debates as I
left office that the recession deepened
and the challenges uh were difficult we
actually had reserves about 30 million
dollars in reserves
the problem is the the recession was
deep enough that that didn't cover it
all
when it comes to the fiscal
responsibility
I know the budgets I have always been a
guardian of the budget I questioned the
expenditures that we make so that I feel
comfortable that we're going to get a
return on that investment in this
community it's easy to sit back and just
say things and that there's a lot of
that that goes on in any campaign but
the assertion that I have somehow been
unethical and I have been unresponsive
to the financial challenges and
responsibilities that I owe are
ridiculous there is no foundation for
any of that
I can't you know I don't remember all of
the things that you just mentioned but
but the reality is that I think I've
done a good job he even says that I'm a
career politician the reality is my
career is working in the things I've
worked at I had a law firm for many
years today I'm a president of a waste
management Waste Company
I have a day job I have always had a day
job I'm not someone who's relied
exclusively on a pen a a payment from
government to survive I do this because
I want to make a difference and I think
the businesses ably represented by me
not only that I have a large family and
we're everywhere we're in the school
district we're everywhere and I care
about what we leave behind and I've felt
motivated to continue to work in
government because I think I can make a
difference so that the quality of life
that my family enjoys over time when I'm
finished will have been protected so you
know this it's easy to to get up and
make loose uh assertions about people
but let's see what the detail is and I'm
happy to discuss the detail
um I want to talk about the future we
talked a little bit maybe too much about
the past here the future here one of the
major issues for Clark County is water
you and I have talked about this before
if you're re-elected next four years
what can Clark County do you're talking
about getting a seat at the table what
can Clark County do to try and address
what's happening at Lake Mead Beyond
issues with Turf and pools and so forth
well keep in mind that four percent of
the water that comes out of Lake Mead
comes to Nevada four percent so what
what we've been doing is preparing
ourselves for whatever the next
iteration of challenges on the river may
be my opponent thinks that the reason
the lake is going down is that
California is taking too much water out
it wouldn't matter if California were
doing our program
there would still not be enough water in
the lake because there's a drought
when it comes to preparing for the
future keep in mind that the third straw
that we've built a billion and a half
dollars worth of we all paid for we have
no federal money in that
the people who live in southern Nevada
paid for that so no one else can control
what we do with that straws fully
authorized we're the only state
and the only region that will be able to
pump water out of that Lake if it ever
gets to a place where it can't produce
power so in terms of protecting
ourselves there are are 20 or 30 feet of
an entire Lake that are above our intake
and that's a lot of water and we believe
that our 50-year resource plan is a
legitimate plan but there are other
things that are being discussed now
other kinds of things I mean there's a
lot of loose discussion about a building
a canal or building a pipeline and you
know what training Lake Powell well you
can't drain Lake Powell because if the
Western grid goes down what we've
discovered is that the only source of
energy in in an immediate jolt that we
have in the Western United States to
restart the Western grid is Glen Canyon
Dam so that's not an option that's the
reason why that's a reason why the the
department of interior is protecting the
uh the Lake Powell level levels and
they're protecting our levels too so my
feeling is that there will be some
things that may be really different and
cool I don't know exactly where it will
come from but we're looking at every
option but keep in mind we are a very
small state this is a political question
and the more when you start thinking
about what kind of political reach we
have independent lead just by ourselves
hey States let us take some of the water
that is draining and running in your
Rivers that's not an easy sell so we're
we're saying to ourselves we can't rely
on anyone else that's the reason why
we're being pretty aggressive very
aggressive in terms of conserving and
that's the reason we spent a billion and
a half dollars to get something down low
enough that we know will have water for
the for the future final question here
you're re-elected you back in January
2023 first thing you want to do
well the the very first thing we're
going to do is get in front of us the
things that we've been working on and
figure out which of those are going to
be successful and then press forward to
to close the the door uh on things that
make no sense one of the things that
we've done a good job of and I have to
say this
things need to keep going pretty much
the way they're going we're doing a good
job with water we have now figured out
some things that will help us with
affordable housing there's a lot more to
be done but we're on the way when it
comes to so many of the other issues
that are out there the transportation
issues the issues that are relate to
sustainability all of that is something
that we have made enormous progress on
and what we need to do is certify our
energy levels to be where they need to
be and then press forward with the
things that make sense and not we will
continue to do what I said a moment ago
we'll sort out the things that don't
make sense that we can't make progress
on in the immediate future and and we'll
continue to surround ourselves with
people that are smarter than we are and
get the kind of help we need and a
public debate is something that is a
good thing and we'll continue to have it
well thank you for coming in to speak
with us I appreciate it commissioner Jim
Gibson running for re-election in
District G in Clark County good luck
with you thank you